la pandémie n'est pas rien ni personne
sauf les ultra riches voilà ce que
révèle le dernier rapport de la
confédération oxfam dont la parution
coïncide avec l'ouverture du 51e forum
économique mondial à l'échelle de la
planète
la fortune des milliardaires les plus
riches a augmenté de 3900 milliards
d'euros entre le 18 mars et le 31
décembre 2020 alors qu'il ne faudrait
bien souvent que quelques millions pour
sauver des secteurs en difficulté dans
des pays très pauvres
écoutons max lawson chargée de campagne
chez oxfam
or après la crise financière il y a plus
de dix ans il a fallu cinq ans à la
fortune des milliardaires pour qu'elle
revienne à son niveau initial
cette fois cela n'a pris que neuf mois
donc c'est une période de boom pour les
milliardaires comme nous le savons les
gens ordinaires à travers le monde sont
confrontées à la peur du virus de la
mort et de la maladie mais aussi perdre
leur travail et il ya les problèmes de
faim qui sont liés c'est une toute autre
histoire pour les gens d'en bas
selon une étude réalisée par la banque
suisse ubs et le cabinet de conseil
pricewaterhousecoopers en octobre 2020
la fortune cumulée des milliardaires
représente dix mille 200 milliards de
dollars soit un nouveau record et ce
grâce aux profits générés dans le
domaine de la santé des équipements
médicaux de la technologie selon
bloomberg il donne masque est
officiellement devenu l'homme le plus
riche du monde avec une fortune estimée
à 2 101 milliards de dollars il
supplante jeff bezos ce le créateur
d'amazon de 20 milliards en france la
fortune de bernard arnault quatrième
homme le plus riche de la planète a
progressé de 41% en 2020 toujours dans
l'hexagone cette milliardaire possède
plus que les 30 % des français les plus
démunis
pas mal pour un pays censés faire fuir
les plus aisés sous le poids du
matraquage fiscal comme on le peut
l'entendre régulièrement dans la bouche
d'une certaine classe politique
et pendant que les coupes de la fortune
des milliardaires tutoie les sommets la
précarité redouble à cause de la
pandémie fin novembre l'observatoire des
inégalités a averti que la france
comptez pas moins de 5,3 millions de
personnes vivant avec moins de 900 euros
par mois
si l'épidémie de kovy de creuser les
inégalités
ce déséquilibre se retrouve aussi dans
les perspectives de vaccination ont ce
pays dont les etats-unis et la chine
concentre 90 % des doses injectées de
très nombreux pays pauvres intermédiaire
donc pas encore eu accès au vaccin
il faut dire que le dispositif mondial
kovacs censé leur venir en aide
s'est fait doubler par les commandes des
pays riches alors que faire oxfam
propose de taxer la fiscalité des
personnes et des entreprises les plus
riches grâce à l'impôt sur la fortune
aux taxes sur les transactions
financières ou à la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
l'argentine quant à elle a créé un impôt
extraordinaire sur les grandes fortunes
pour lutter contre la pandémie
antonio gutiérrez secrétaire général de
l'onu plaide pour sa part en faveur d'un
new deal mondial où le pouvoir les
ressources et les opportunités serait
mieux partagés quant à joe biden il a
promis d'augmenter les impôts des plus
fortunés
même le fmi a conseillé au gouvernement
d'augmenter les impôts des familles et
des entreprises les mieux lotis alors
puisque tout le monde est d'accord le
changement c'est maintenant